but aren't there other major holidays
during Christmas time beside Christmas
and New Year's this is usually what they
ask now really there are holidays to be
sure but no major ones the closest
contender we have is Hanukkah which is
the Jewish festival of lights but while
Hanukkah is indeed an ancient holiday it
dates back about 2,000 years it is a
relatively minor holiday major Jewish
holidays are biblical they feature
restrictions on work because Hanukkah is
non biblical there are few religious
restrictions on work according to
historian Diane Ashton Hanukkah rose to
prominence in America as it did not in
the rest of the world because of two
reform rabbis in 19th century Cincinnati
who worried their children had a little
connection to the synagogue before that
there is a little record of Hanukkah
celebrations the rabbi's modeled the
celebration in gift-giving after
Christmas as Ashton explains quote they
didn't see Christmas as something they
could do easily because it's Christian
but they did want to do something like
that because it was American so kosher
restaurants even started serving turkey
dinners after the American custom that's
Hanukkah the far less credible Pretender
is Kwanzaa which is a socialist
contrivance invented by a criminal LA
City College Africana Studies professor
named Maulana Karenga in 1966 he created
Kwanzaa to be a holiday specifically for
black Americans even though black
Americans already celebrated Christmas
ironically while virtually all African
slaves were brought to America from the
west coast of Africa Kwanzaa is a
Swahili word meaning firstfruits that
originated in East Africa which means
none of the slaves brought to America
would have understood it now one of the
seven principles of Kwanzaa is communism
bujjamma cooperative economics and
Maulana Karenga himself was sentenced to
prison in 1971 for felonious assault and
false imprisonment after he sexually
assaulted and tortured multiple women as
the LA Times reported he ordered them to
strip naked whipped them with an
electrical cord and beat them with the
karate baton Karenga then placed a hot
soldering iron in one woman's mouth and
against her face and tightened her big
toe and a vise he finally put detergent
and running hoses in their mouths and
hit them on the head with toasters as
the Black Power movement of the 1970s
has waned so too has the celebration of
the holiday on the high end of estimates
point three percent of Americans
acknowledge the supposed holiday that
rate continues to decline so why pretend
Christmas time does not center around
Christmas why pretend there are so many
other major holidays on equal footing
there's new year on January 1st and
we've long said good tiding for
Christmas in a happy new year there's
Chanukah a relatively minor holiday but
by the way we don't say Happy Holidays
instead of happy Labor Day even though
Rosh Hashanah which is a far more
important Jewish holiday than Chanukah
sometimes occurs around the same time
you don't say that we don't say happy
holidays or season's greetings instead
of happy Columbus Day even though Yom
Kippur another much more important
Jewish holiday sometimes occurs around
that time well actually now we don't say
happy Columbus Day either we say blessed
indigenous peoples day or something like
that that's another story beer is
Kwanzaa virtually non-existent holiday
what else is there there's Boxing Day in
which no one in the United States
celebrates there's the winter solstice
which people pretend is a thing but
nobody celebrates and of course it isn't
about the the celebrants of Hanukkah or
Kwanzaa or the winter solstice who are
waging the war on Christmas it's the
Atheist left who constantly seeks to
replace clear vivid language with
bizarre secular euphemisms this is the
essence of political correctness that
the essence of political correctness is
to replace clear language with
euphemisms to remove the strength of
that language